if world war iii started tonight would
america be ready
the vice chairman of the joint chiefs
doesn't seem confident after a tough
loss in a classified war gaming exercise
he issued a dire warning without
overstating
the issue it failed miserably
uh an aggressive red team that had been
studying
the united states for the last 20 years
just ran rings around us and they knew
exactly what we're going to do before we
did it
and they they took advantage of it how
can america regain its status as the
military powerhouse of the world
congressman mike gallagher is a former
marine counter intelligence officer
he joins us now mike i'm going heavy
with the wisconsin guests early on
good to have you here i know that you
had a recent report
that delved into the readiness capacity
of the navy and other aspects of this
that
really should concern i think every
american tell us a little bit about what
you found
well the report which interviewed over
70 individuals both active duty and
recently retired concluded that there's
a strong sense
in the navy that we've lost our focus on
warfighting we've lost our focus on
warfighting due to
the increased cost of maintenance but
really a disinvestment
in training for basic seamanship at a
time when we're layering on
more administrative requirements and
therefore we've lost that warfighting
focus and i think you add on to that a
lot of this woke nonsense that's
infecting our military right now
we need warriors ben we need warriors
not
wokesters and we have increasingly woke
general officers and flag officers
because the biden administration is
sending the signal
that america is systemically racist and
white supremacy
is endemic to all of our institutions
including the military
which is absolute nonsense i was
deployed in diverse units nobody cared
about the color of anyone's skin
all that mattered was whether you could
do the job can you fire your weapon
accurately can you operate the radio how
many pull-ups can you do these are the
things marines concern themselves with
not with implicit bias we optimize our
military
not for diversity or equity but for
lethality for the basic ability to close
with and destroy the enemy
and we've lost sight of that and we're
doing the favor a huge favor to the
chinese communist party in the process
have we seeded uh control of the sea
mr nimbus style to china in a way that
they will be able to dominate
uh going forward for the foreseeable
future
is this something that we're really
climbing out of a hole in order to be
able to compete with them
well i'm sure your audience got the rick
and morty reference there ben
but uh we we have seated control we've
been arguing about
creating a 355-ship navy for the last
few years but
china went out and did it and more to
the point you were you referenced the
war games that we keep losing
the only change has been that we're
losing at a faster rate in these war
games so
there is no coherent plan for the
defense of taiwan and that really is the
most
stressing scenario that we need to plan
around how do we deter
the pla from invading taiwan by denial
and we don't have that plan right now
and we're not
investing accordingly i think we can do
it
but it's going to require us to act with
a sense of urgency and above all it's
going to require us
to abandon this narrative that suggests
that america is an evil racist hellscape
because the chinese communist party
co-opts that narrative and uses it
against us it weaponizes the rhetoric
of the far left to divide us congressman
is this a situation where we have
allowed
our general class to essentially become
these aging politicians
who deploy wokeness in a way that allows
them to
keep their positions without requiring
them to do the hard work of preparing
our military
well i think the risk is if the
president the secretary of defense and
all the service chiefs are basically
sending the signal that we are going to
prioritize
the dei agenda the diversity equity and
inclusion agenda
there's naturally going to be a tendency
among those seeking to get into the
general officer flag officer ranks to
respond to that political demand signal
and we don't want to promote politicians
we want to promote
war fighters and we have to go back to
the basics of seamanship
and warfighting otherwise we are going
to continue to do more damage
to our own navy than the chinese navy
could ever dream of doing
congressman thank you so much for taking
the time to join me today hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else